ever since it was awarded the Oscar for
Best Picture there's been a lot of extra
attention on the shape of water that's
what happened you win better accurately
a lot more attention settling it's a
very romantic film and as a lot of you
know it's about a woman who falls in
love with a half-man half-fish it was a
very very moving story that touched a
lot of hearts and and now a lot more
people are seeing the movie out sure and
it's maybe changing the culture Eddie
well just made me want to ask our
cameraman Alex something hey Alex how's
it going man I don't you mean how's it
going what you mean know what I mean is
I just figured you know shape of water
it's pretty romantic you got a very
specific look so you must be cleaning up
right now you know what I mean oh yeah
yeah yeah I've actually got five dates
lined up this week one of them was a
Victoria's Secret model oh yeah really
huh
no I'm half-fish women aren't exactly
stuffing hard-boiled eggs down my
g-string turns out in real life being
covered in scales and a protein-rich
mucus isn't exactly a panty dropper
no I'm sorry to hear that I just thought
maybe the movie would help you out a
little bit you know what I mean oh yeah
sure right yeah like how after King Kong
came out all those women were hopping
fences at the zoo so they could bone
gorilla alright alright okay I get it it
doesn't maybe work that way if you tried
online dating oh yeah I've tried all the
apps tinder grinder bumble bubble
flipper trawler blowhole
plenty of fish crabs list scales and
tails okay - all right okay a lot of
dates fish Leigh Madison barely Guppies
Chum Bucket bang boat hook line and 2 in
the pinker and farmers only you know
what I haven't had a bite in months all
right listen maybe you maybe just need
to turn up the old charm a bit you know
with a clever pickup line do you have
any oh yeah okay yeah sure how about
this hi I'm Alex I'm half fish how about
we get out of here and go someplace damp
okay no all right yeah that's not gonna
work but maybe something a little sexier
than that okay yeah so you're saying
yeah here's one hey girl let's say we
grab a cocktail some worms then head
back to your place where you poop out a
couple hundred thousand eggs and I power
wash them with my fish juice okay listen
no I don't know what to say maybe you
could just join a local kickball team or
something I'm half fish
Conan what part of that don't you get
I'm a freak if Charles Darwin saw me
he'd crap his pants okay all right I'm
sorry I brought it up that's Alex our
cameraman you know what that movie's
[ __ ] - by the way I don't even know
how to find my piece we're gonna take a
break we're back David Oh yellow oh I'm
sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
you